let me bring in Brady Quinn Brady is
gonna be covering the big shootout there
State Fair of Texas between Oklahoma
it's called the red river showdown not a
shootout anymore it's a showdown there
between Texas and Oklahoma
Brady thanks for joining us all right we
stumbled upon this question
pre-show if I said to Tom Brady
privately I could get you Beckham or you
stay with Edelman who would he take I
think he'd take I don't know at this
point Jimmy said fir'd I would that's a
tough question answer for me I'm not as
talented as tom is so I would need
someone with the talent and ability of
Odell Beckham to be able to make you
look good as a quarterback sometimes so
I would probably need a wide receiver
like Odell Beckham or Julio Jones or all
those guys you would discuss stacked
Braylon Edwards my rookie year the way
he played that year you know you need
that sometimes unless you are Tom Brady
arguably the greatest of all time and
you can move in the pocket the way he
does put the ball wherever he wants I
mean that then allows a guy like Julian
Edelman it meant my mind at least to
have more production that had a bigger
career in it's strange though what are
you getting ready to turn you 34 gonna
be 35 35 here shortly okay and this dude
at 42 is doing what he's doing and then
you got to be nice and Phillip Rivers
and Ben Roethlisberger like what do you
think when you see those guys out there
it's it's incredible it speaks to you
not only one what they've been able to
accomplish but but I also think the
situations that they answer into you
know those are much more stable
situations the the ownership of those
teams to as much as you always want to
put on the quarterback there's also a
lot of variables and circumstances that
they walked into that I think helped
them be become the quarterbacks that
they are you know I mean if you look at
what Ben Roethlisberger was when he
first got there as a rookie and some of
his early success you know and then what
he was later on I mean it's an entirely
different story you could maybe even
make that case a little bit for Tom
Brady when he took over for blood so I
mean that defense for the Patriots was
nasty and now at the end of his career
ironically they've got another number
one defense in the NFL I'm looking at
these quarterback
now coming out of college and I don't
know how to troubleshoot handicap them
and I don't know if you can either but I
know Justin Herbert's supposed to be
great Trevor Lawrence is supposed to be
great too is supposed to be great now
all of a sudden Jalen Hertz might be a
first-round draft pick you know this is
a fluid subject here and trying to
figure out how the a out you know Daniel
Jones who would have thought so how do
you look at these quarterbacks if you're
asked to projective how you think
they'll perform in the NFL well I think
the one thing about all of those guys is
they each one of them has this this one
quality that stands out more so than
everything else and so if you're talking
about Herbert and Ann have you ever seen
him in person no but I've heard he's a
big dude he's he's really impressive and
I didn't really I did their bowl game
last year versus Michigan State and from
watching the tape in the film just from
an overall like playing the position I
kind of was thinking to myself yeah like
I'm not sure what all the hype is about
this guy and then I went down on the
field before the game and you see that
he's six foot six
he throws absolute lasers I mean the
ball just coming out of his hand and
he's a great athlete he's a really good
kid you see all these other qualities
that you say okay I get it like now I
understand why people look at him and
they think imagine what he could be as
he as he becomes more refined as a
quarterback and I think this year he's
actually showcased that a little bit too
you know to uh just has a really good
sense for foresee in the field his
timing his rhythm within the offense and
even in the pocket and just ability to
make plays like eg kind of reminds you a
little bit of at you know at times
Russell Wilson because he does always he
moves around but he keeps his eyes
downfield he really doesn't want to run
he wants to take those big shots and
he's kind of my like left-handed version
of Russell Wilson that you see I'm not
sure he has that the same arm strength
but but they're close you know and then
you keep going down the line and talking
about some of these guys major Joe
pearls an interesting one because this
year he's taken such a big step forward
that I think some people may start
looking at him saying okay there this
guy named Joe Brady who was with the
Saints he's coming down he's putting in
more NFL style
plays and progressions for them and he
is flourishing down there he's making
this LSU team illegitimate contender and
so people are gonna start getting him a
lot more consideration because how he
operates within the system and how he
handles everything in that offense so
every one of those guys that I mentioned
has like one or two qualities they just
stand out amongst everyone else and they
can all make them first-round picks and
successful quarterbacks but I kind of go
back to what I said about all the guys
who are going to be Hall of Famers it's
it's the situation circumstance they
enter into I think that's that's
paramount to even some of these
qualities that I'm talking about because
quarterman she doesn't have any of those
qualities as good as the guys I just
named let me zakir it he's obviously
athletic enough he's got a strong enough
arm he's got the best personality you'll
find in any one of these quarterbacks
but he's also in a situation where his
defense can help him out he's got some
over the running game and they don't put
too much on his plate order for him to
win games
he's Brady Quinn full cast big noon
kickoff live from the State Fair of
Texas for pregame coverage red river
showdown beginning at 10:00 a.m. Eastern
that'll be Saturday on Fox I was
mentioning if I'm Lincoln riling the
quarterback whisperer at least the new
one I wouldn't leave Oklahoma for a job
like the Washington Redskins and I would
I would have serious doubts about let's
say the Dallas Cowboys job opened up
what what do you think it would take to
get Lincoln Riley to leave Oklahoma
probably a Brinks truck full of like 15
million a year so about some ridiculous
amount of money that was just we've
never heard before
one job opportunity though Brady because
you don't want to go to Washington okay
no no probably Dallas I mean it's the
Dallas Cowboys it's Jerry Jones you know
you you got you're gonna be a head coach
of the most valuable sports franchise in
the world it would be hard to turn that
down along with a huge contract I think
one thing we've seen too at least from
from watching you with Nick Saban you up
to your NFL or you know I'm Steve
Spurrier you can strike it out you can
come right back down and you'll be fine
now the problem is you know you may not
have that opportunity they're waiting
for you like Oklahoma and how they have
that thing running right now where when
we can rally took over for Bob Stoops
it was just kind of business as usual
and we're gonna try to you know
ratcheting up this thing up another
notch and see if we can win a national
championship how important is this game
USC Notre Dame who is it more important
to that's a good question I would say
it's probably more important to Notre
Dame if they want to stay within you
know that conversation I was like all
right like where do they maybe sit as
11-1 team with the schedule that they
played I don't think they get in but I
but I think it also it kind of verifies
them as this team that is Allen has
arrived and maybe they're not to the
likes of a Georgia even though I'd love
to see that game played on a neutral
site and how that would have worked out
for them or you know the Ohio State's
and the Clemson and the bamas but
they're right there I mean I think
they're inching closer and closer and
closer to with every recruiting class
and when as this group continues to
develop so it's probably more important
that them but you can make the case as
far as clay heldens job security if he
doesn't win this one you know that that
chatter is gonna get a lot louder yeah
but we know I don't think he can win his
way into another year unfortunately for
clay let's just play out the scenario
okay let's say they let's say they do
upset Notre Dame let's say they go on to
win the pac-12 and then they go on to
win a Rose Bowl at that point cuz
they're not getting in the playoff it
it'd be part of the new year six right
are you gonna fire a coach after winning
the pac-12 when the Rose Bowl dad I
wouldn't but you know that you bring in
a new athletic director a new athletic
director usually brings in a new head
coach it's not a bad precedent to set
okay I understand
but but I think maybe it just prolongs
another year where you see how they
perform in 2020 and then you're
reevaluate in the situation I also think
is you know as a new athletic director
once you want to kind of get settled
into before you start making a bunch of
decisions that's really not you know
understanding how this all operates
maybe I don't know maybe they bring in
another USC alum which would probably be
a terrible decision based off their
track record right now spoken like a
true Notre Dame Fighting Irish from in
there what was the saying man I'm just
trying to be I'm just trying to be
objective course you help them out
right now last year hires have not
worked out for us see let's try
something different let's try to think
outside the box
maybe we bring in someone who's just
really good at the job right maybe maybe
we should do something like that wasn't
it 14 years ago coming up but do you
celebrate the anniversary of the bush
push you throw things against the law is
Jalen Hurd's now a first-round draft
pick no III based on what I've watched
field songs you know I mean for starters
I'd say he hasn't even really been
tested I mean let's just go back to last
week they only put up 45 points and only
had like five hundred and forty-five
yards of total offense and that was
their worst performance of the year so
far so I mean they haven't been tested
and so this this week will really I
didn't give us a sense or tell what he
could potentially be as a prospect cuz I
do think their defensive coordinator at
Texas caught Orlando is gonna force him
to try to play from the pocket talking
with some of the staff at Oklahoma - you
get the sense that like some of these
big runs that occur that aren't
necessarily designed in the offense
they're frustrated because he's taking
off and making that play and as much as
you want to say well yeah we want to
limit him in his ability to run when he
sees an opening because he's so dynamic
there's also this other thought that if
Oklahoma runs the table and when's the
big 12 during the playoff or even maybe
with a one loss but still when they get
to those matches against some of the top
defenses you can't do that I mean look
at last year Trevor Lawrence playing
from the pocket time see there on a boo
but you know even the Shaun Watson go
back when you look at the times the
team's been able to win the national
championship
they still have to have a fair amount of
play from the pocket and I think that's
what they're looking for him to do it
and that's what life is in the NFL you
know you can run around as much as you
want you're eventually gonna get hurt
and eventually teams are gonna figure
out what your weaknesses are so you have
to be able play from the pocket I don't
know that he's really demonstrated the
ability or been tested and forced to do
that yet are you mad at the Dallas
Cowboys mad hmm why would I be mad well
didn't the Browns trade up with the
Cowboys to select you
they did they did yeah I mean that's
completely out of my control how would I
William yeah again where did you think
you were going I thought I was going to
be going to Miami at nine I mean we were
charlie weis that received a care
package from the Dolphins like the night
before and so I'm at this you know
there's these different marketing events
you go to and I get a call from him and
he said hey you're gonna be a Miami
Dolphin like what do you mean he said
well I just got a care package and I
denotes that we know you have a big fan
before but you will after tomorrow kind
of going back to his days in a
coordinator in New England and going up
against Miami twice a year and so when
it didn't happen we were all pretty
surprised by the fact I mean just from
the rapport from the visits everything
else is just it seemed like it was
heading in that direction and then it
didn't and so at that point I really
wasn't sure what to expect
what's the care package I think it was
like a sweatshirt and I look these
organizations are cheap it could have
been much dad oh and then then all of a
sudden you know who does Miami take they
took Ted yet he's still playing still
boy and then you go wait I'm supposed to
be good do you think because Ginn was
there that they had to take him I don't
know I'm not sure what those
conversations were going on in that room
I mean look the Dolphins want one is 15
that year cam camera got fired so hey
Brady great to talk to you and happy
birthday coming up have fun this weekend
I appreciate that guys for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]